it's time for a peace summit between the
warring factions so I've asked Israel to
come up with an exercise to promote
communication and trust between the
kitchen and the front of house teams you
have your onions into it and you start
smashing yeah or matter going to be
making guacamole but there's a twist
other teams are Phillip you're partnered
up with David ha the person in the back
is actually making the guacomole but
you're all gonna be putting a blindfold
on so you're gonna have to depend on the
person in front of you directing you ie
we're gonna have to depend on the
restaurant help in the kitchen and the
kitchen helping the restaurant put his
blindfold on if you're the head not the
neck phase will be hands behind your
back yeah three minutes starting from
now
[Music]
he's a peach in a pinch
Oh pinch halfway there
eat it Munya oh sure where the finger is
right how we doing without stop holding
friends yeah okay this one Oh hmm that's
what nice nothings mushed up so whose
fault was that
Linnaeus I guess I was the one that
couldn't see what was it hmm not bad
nice those no Tabasco in there David
Phillips yours were the best oh yeah I
think Dave gave me more encouragement
there in the last three minutes that he
has done in two years no matter what
happens from this day on you guys have
got to get on because if the head chef
and the general manager get on and
everybody else underneath you follow
suit to understand the importance of
that grow up and start orderly start do
it earlier give me kiss here's the
bonding a happy couple Cheers
Philip and I thought okay again the
bonding masters one small step for
Philip and Dave but potentially a huge
lead for the business I am never gonna
put your finger in my mouth again you
put your finger yours my finger agent
Jesus
you